[music]
>> I'm Mathias. I hope you're having a
wonderful time at IO.
I'm colleagues with Yuna and Bramus who
were on stage just right before me. And
together with you all, I want to do a
deep dive on one of the announcements we
made on the developer keynote stage
yesterday.
Chrome DevTools for Agents.
In the next 20 minutes, I'll cover what
it is,
what it's useful for, and how you can
get started yourself.
So, first, for those who are new to this
or new to the web track at Google IO,
welcome. This here on the screen is
DevTools.
It's what opens when you right-click in
Chrome and then select inspect.
DevTools is what you'll trial and error
around in to find the right combination
of CSS properties to make your things
look as planned as in Yuna's and Bramus'
talk.
In September last year,
>> [snorts]
>> the same DevTools you know and love got
a new UI surface
additional to what you'll get when you
right-click and inspect.
Chrome DevTools for Agents. Let's dive
in.
We're going to start with a general
overview of what Chrome DevTools for
Agents is,
where it lives, how it relates to your
other tools, and how your agent can use
it.
Then, we're going to look at the
foundational technologies that enable
the capabilities of DevTools for Agents.
Having a basic understanding of this
will be the foundation to understand the
actual capabilities and use cases
before we look into the various
configuration options and finally how
you can get started. But first, we're
going to do some time travel.
I want to take you on a virtual trip
back in time to the beginning of your
career.
Whenever this was.
Maybe it's been a couple of months, 3
years, or decades ago. That doesn't
really matter. Just try to think how it
was as an absolute web developer
beginner.
For me, this was in 2014.
This was me back then. That's my first
corporate profile picture on the day I
joined as an apprentice web developer to
learn web development.
I was part of a team of around 20 other
engineers who were taking turns in
teaching me web development over the
course of 2 years.
The one thing all my colleagues had in
common, they used DevTools to show and
demonstrate things to me.
For example, I learned that the static
HTML from my code editor turns into a
dynamic living thing called DOM by
clicking through the elements panel.
Later in my career, I learned about web
performance by running Lighthouse audits
over and over again and just lightly
following the advice it gave me until
the scores turned green
without really understanding the
background.
So, [snorts] for me, DevTools enabled a
closed feedback loop during my learning
journey.
Through DevTools, I could inspect the
live page I was working on,
fiddle with it, try and break things,
and debug issues.
And this has been true for me just as
millions of other developers out there,
including you, before and after us.
But, there are a few developers who
learned web development without ever
touching DevTools.
They are over 3 years into their career
now, and they are doing a fairly decent
job, I would say, but they never touched
DevTools.
I'm talking about coding agents,
obviously.
We think they are missing out and could
do more if we give them the right tools.
We believe that giving your coding agent
access to dev tools through dev tools
for agents enables the same close
feedback loop for them you benefited
from your whole career.
Let's look at a debugging example.
The way you would manually handle it
even with AI in the game.
This is a sign up form using a company's
internal auth provider called short
sign.
It's not publicly documented, so no AI
model knows about it.
When I try to register and it fails, I
only get cryptic error messages like app
error 1003.
Your out-of-the-box coding agent runs
into a bunch of dead ends debugging an
issue like this.
First of all, it would rely on you to
manually surface the issue.
But then also if you actually surface
the issue already and you prompt "Please
fix app error 1003 in sign up form tsx
when trying to sign up with your coding
agent." It can't do much really. It will
search for app error 1003 across the
code base and then just spiral.
If it got lucky after some digging, my
coding agent might find this lousy to do
comment I left for it. To do: handle
specific error code. Excellent, right?
Little does my coding agent know that
the solution is actually not too far.
Any wild guesses where it is?
Is it A in the training data of the
model?
Or is it B in the source code? Or is it
C in the runtime data?
After you listened to my heartwarming
story of how I learned that development,
you will know it's C. The solution is in
the runtime data.
Let me show you where.
When I'm submitting the sign-up form, a
request is being sent to an API.
And all network requests sent from a
page are surfaced in DevTools.
It's the same here.
So, when we look in the network panel in
DevTools, inspect the failing request,
and look at the response,
we see there is actually an additional
message that we can use to give the user
more information.
And not only can we use those network
requests, but our coding agent as well.
Giving your coding agent access to this
information through DevTools enables
this closed feedback loop I mentioned
before.
But, let's see if that's true by giving
it a test run.
Before we can do that, though, we need
to tweak our prompt just so slightly.
Instead of asking our agent to look at
specific files, we ask it to look at the
runtime.
As DevTools for agents has access to
source maps, it will be able to guide
your coding agent to the right file
anyway.
So, we are going with go to localhost,
sign up, debug and fix the error when
signing up with test and 1 2 3 4.
Using this prompt with my coding agent
at Gravity in this case, and DevTools
for agents enabled, will start a full
end-to-end fixing flow.
The agent will open the page in a real
Chrome instance, try to log in, capture
any console logs or network requests,
and combine all the pointers to actually
fix the code.
That's the power of DevTools for agents.
All right. So, after you've seen this
first example of what Chrome DevTools
for agents can do, let's briefly look
into the foundation of it all.
As this will help you get a better
understanding of the use cases we'll
explore in just a minute.
While DevTools for agencies new,
it's actually built on a pretty solid
and long-standing foundation.
Using tools the same team has been
maintaining for years.
From Puppeteer and Puppeteer. But let's
break it down.
At its core, DevTools for agents is an
NPM package that you can install on any
machine that has a recent Node.js
version.
This is what your coding agent is using.
May it be antigravity, Gemini CLI, or
whatever you prefer.
Your agent might either use it through
the MCP server
or the CLI, which both ship as part of
the same NPM package.
The CLI enables your coding agent to
script against DevTools for agents,
which can be more token efficient
compared to using it through the MCP
server.
The third and last key thing that brings
it all together is a set of skills,
which teach your coding agent how and
when to use Chrome DevTools for agents.
For now, Chrome DevTools for agents
ships with a total of six skills, which
can be roughly put in two categories.
The troubleshooting and the Chrome
DevTools and Chrome DevTools CLI skills
help your coding agent to understand key
capabilities, concepts, and general
usage.
The accessibility debugging, the memory
leak dub
>> [laughter]
>> memory leak debugging, and optimize LCP
skills include expert knowledge in that
specific area, which makes your coding
agent act as the same expert.
As part of modern web guidance, you
might have heard about it in the keynote
yesterday or in Phil's talk, this skill
set will expand over the coming months
to help your agent debug the web's
newest features.
To learn more about modern web guidance,
find Phil's session unlock modern web
capabilities in your AI coding workflows
from yesterday on YouTube to learn more.
Now, from skills back to the overall
architecture. DevTools for agents is an
NPM package with skills and MCP server
and a CLI.
The thing we haven't looked into yet,
how does any of this talk to Chrome?
Through Puppeteer. The same library from
the Chrome tooling team that you might
have used in the past to run tests,
automate an annoying workflow, or scrape
something.
While this layer is mostly invisible
when you're using DevTools for agents,
it's helpful to know this because
ultimately it's Puppeteer giving
DevTools for agents its capabilities.
And before we get into those, knowing
Puppeteer is the layer in between might
also help you better assess security and
when to use Chrome DevTools for agents.
For example, under one of our recent
YouTube tutorials, someone recently
asked, "Does DevTools for agents have
access to my passwords saved in Chrome's
password manager?"
The clear answer is no.
DevTools for agents does not have
[snorts] access to password saved in
Chrome's password manager.
It is not using Chrome like you are as a
human user.
It's only using a vetted and tested set
of tools through Puppeteer.
And Puppeteer doesn't expose that as a
capability.
But also, DevTools for agents uses a
separate, anonymous browser profile by
default.
And while this largely reduces a few of
the most common security risks around
giving agents access to a browser.
The advice to always carefully decide
what you give agents access to never
gets old.
No matter how boring it sounds, it's
critical to protect your personal data.
Awesome. So, now that we fully explored
how it works under the hood, let's dive
into some examples of what it can
actually do.
As you just learned, DevTools for agents
inherits its capabilities from
Puppeteer.
But, when you prompt your coding agent,
your agent doesn't directly use
Puppeteer.
Instead, we wrapped key Puppeteer
capabilities in a set of distinct tools,
properly described, and by this easier
to consume by your coding agent.
Those tools can be divided into six
overall categories.
In this section, I want to walk you
through three different use case
examples, exploring how tools from
multiple categories play together to
fulfill a certain user prompt.
The first example is the one you've
already seen.
With a prompt like, "Go to localhost,
debug and fix the error when signing up
with test and 1234." We had the coding
agent navigate to the page, fill in the
form, and then fix the underlying error
and validate its own fix, all in a real
Chrome instance running on my machine.
This example combines input automation,
network, and navigation automation.
Our partner Cyber Agent has brought this
use case to the next level when they set
up an agent with access to DevTools for
agents and let it audit over 230 stories
in Storybook across 32 components in
just 1 hour of run time.
To learn more about this, find the case
study on developer.chrome.com.
For the next example, we are going to
combine emulation tools, which allow dev
tools for agents to change the viewport
size, for example, and debugging tools
like taking a screenshot.
Combining them enables your coding agent
to do one of bug validation.
So, before you manually go through a
bug's verification process, let your
agent
work for you first.
For example, if you have a report about
not all navigation items being visible
on all devices, you can prompt
Go [snorts] to developer.chrome.com.
Check the same navigation items are
visible on desktop, tablet, and mobile
viewports.
After you sent your coding agent,
Antigravity will open a Chrome window
and use the emulation tools to resize
the viewport to desktop, tablet, and
mobile one after another.
As a sign of this, in this screencast,
you see the page occasionally overlap
the window bounds.
Then, in the second example, Antigravity
took screenshots, interacted with the
burger menu on mobile, and cross-checked
everything before it will ultimately
return the response in the screencast.
The response will be something along the
lines of The same four main navigation
items are present across all three
viewports.
While the items themselves remain
consistent, their placement and
presentation adapt based on the device.
There you see the final response.
So, with this prompt, I could automate a
testing journey across three viewports
and nested menus, including the
interactions with them, sparing me all
manual work and the back and forth to
remind myself what actually happened on
each viewport.
Okay, let's look at one last use case,
and to be honest, it's really my
favorite one because Chrome dev tools
for agents enables you to scale your
expertise.
For example, let's imagine you don't
know much about web performance and only
have a 57 points lighthouse score. Or
imagine you don't know much about
accessibility or SEO.
Now, you could go in and ask your coding
agent to improve any of the areas
mentioned with a generic prompt like
improve the performance of this project.
With a generic prompt like this and
without dev tools for agents, what will
likely happen is that your coding agent
just slowly starts burning through your
token budget reading all of your project
files and only fixing random things it
might find along the way.
Ultimately, that wouldn't help your
website performance.
But with dev tools for agents,
it's flipped. With its specialized tools
to run performance traces, analyze
[snorts] included insights, and run
accessibility, best practices, SEO, and
the new agentic browsing it's uh
audit in lighthouse, it can actually
test for known problems instead of
trying to guess them from your source
code.
This allows you and your coding agent to
improve your websites in areas you're
not inherently familiar with.
For example, you can work on real
performance issues by letting dev tools
for agents actually measure your current
performance and then work against an
actual target and use performance
insight in the trace to start where it
matters.
All through a prompt like go to
localhost, run a performance trace, and
act on all findings.
Or you can use the same pattern to
improve accessibility instead of your
coding agent and underlying model just
sprinkling in a couple of labels.
Or you use the same pattern to ask your
coding agent to work on SEO.
While all of these examples you've just
seen work with the MCP server and the
CLI equally,
some of them are perfect for the CLI
because the CLI can also run outside of
an agent loop.
This allows you to persist your agent's
actions to shell scripts.
Here's how it works.
After you're done with your debugging
flow with Chrome DevTools for agents,
just prompt
persist your previous actions in
DevTools to a well-named script file
using the DevTools CLI.
When you try a prompt like this, make
sure that your coding agent has access
to the DevTools CLI and the related
skill
which teach it how to use the CLI.
For the previous example where they
validated the navigation on
developer.chrome.com,
this for example could yield a script
like this.
It's opening the page, emulating the
viewports, and taking the screenshots.
The only bit that is missing here is the
actual comparison of the results at the
gravity has done for me in the
screencast earlier.
With this approach using the scripts,
that would be on you the human again.
Okay, let's wrap up all use cases that
we explored.
We saw a prompt to automatically fix
complex UI flows,
one to scale your expertise running
performance traces or Lighthouse audits,
one to validate bug reports, and one to
persist your prompted actions to scripts
you can rerun outside of your coding
agent.
Use variations of those prompts in your
own projects to achieve the same same
results you just saw on screen.
To explore more use cases like this and
more examples from other tool
categories, learn more in our
documentation on developer.chrome.com.
Now, there is one last topic I want to
look into with you. Configuration.
While DevTools for agents works for most
and most use cases out of the box,
there are some configuration options you
can use to tailor to your own needs.
To configure it, when using Chrome
DevTools for agents as an MCP server,
find the file that has your MCP service
config.
For Gemini CLI, this is usually a
.gemini/static.json.
For Cloud, this might be in your project
root at .mcp.json. For other agents, it
is in similar locations you already
know.
In this file, just add a new entry to
the args array with the option you want
to configure.
If you're using DevTools for agents
through the CLI, make sure to explicitly
include your desired option in the
prompt.
For example, through the channel
configuration option, you can specify
whether Chrome DevTools for agents
should connect to any other Chrome
channel than stable.
Or you can use the configuration options
to enable experimental options we are
still working on, like the experimental
support for screencasts through
experimental screencasts.
And for the MCP server users
specifically, there are configuration
options to turn off certain tool
categories to save tokens.
But there is one configuration option I
want to particularly highlight, which is
useful for both users of the CLI and the
MCP server.
It's auto connect.
Think about auto connect as sharing your
screen with your coding agent.
Because auto connect allows your coding
agent to connect to an already running
Chrome instance and pick right up where
you left off.
Let's look into why this is interesting.
For this,
we're going back to our initial example.
We asked our coding agent to go to a
specific page and sign in with a certain
set of credentials.
We did this so our coding agent could
get to the same page state that we
already reproduced in our running
Chrome.
But if I'm already at the same state
with the error right in front of my
eyes,
why should I waste mental energy just to
write a prompt that gets my coding agent
into the same state?
Or even worse, manually copy and paste
error messages from the browser console
into my coding agent.
This is what autoconnect is for, and it
works fairly simple.
All you need to do is to go to Chrome,
inspect, select remote debugging in the
sidebar,
>> [snorts]
>> and then toggle the allow remote up
allow re
Excuse me, allow remote debugging for
this browser instance checkbox.
Then make sure to use autoconnect in
your FCP JSON config or explicitly
prompt for it when using the CLI.
Now, the next time you use your coding
agent, it will connect to the Chrome
you've just been using, and will also
let you know if it has trouble
connecting to it because you forgot to
turn on remote debugging, for example.
However, this is the right time to
repeat the earlier advice.
Carefully decide what you give agents
access to
because with autoconnect, depending on
what Chrome instance you're connecting
to, DevTools for agents might use your
personal Chrome profile rather than the
anonymous default one,
which puts your personal data at risk.
Because technically, connected to my
personal Chrome profile, a prompt like
go to google.com shopping and order 999
colorful balloons has a high chance of
actually succeeding and incurring
unintended costs and consequences like a
lot of balloons ordered to my doorstep.
Because in this example, I might already
be locked into the shop site the agent
ultimately decides to use and the only
thing it needs to do is click next and
continue and check out all the time.
So, carefully consider what you prompt
for when using autoconnect with a
personal profile.
And with this, you really have
everything to get started. You know how
a DevTools for Agents works with the MCP
server and the CLI.
We explored a couple of example prompts
from bug validation to persisting
DevTools actions into a reusable CLI
script.
And you learned how to configure
DevTools for Agents to your needs.
On top of all this, we are happy to
announce that since yesterday, DevTools
for Agents is available in its first
stable release, version 1.0.
However, my team might have shipped
minor fix releases in the meantime, so
let's say roundabout version one. I
think we're at 1.01 or something.
Um
but anyway, stable and good to use.
Now it's time for you to get started.
In the next few slides, I'm going to
share resources for you to install
DevTools for Agents,
learning material to set it up, and how
to contribute back to it if you want to.
First up, find install instructions for
over 20 coding agents, more use cases
including the autoconnect feature you
heard about, and in-depth documentation
through this link on
developer.chrome.com.
If you haven't seen enough of me today,
you can also learn more about setting up
DevTools for Agents with a video
tutorial on YouTube. Find it at
google/dtasetup.
This video is also the beginning of a
series of YouTube videos explaining use
cases for DevTools for Agents that we'll
expand over time.
If you have particular use cases in mind
or want to learn more about, please find
me on social and reach out with your
idea.
And don't forget, DevTools for Agents is
a thriving open source project. If you
see something that doesn't work, want to
peek into feature discussions, or
straight-up contribute, find the project
on GitHub.
Now, that's it.
Thanks so much for listening and
spending your time here at the Chrome
tent. This was a comprehensive overview
of Chrome DevTools for Agents, and we
can't wait for you to get started.
Enjoy the rest of IO and your lunch, and
see you all soon.
>> [applause]
[music]